c'est une scène surréaliste qui s'est
produite cette nuit dans le quartier
saint-jacques de beaune pourtant réputé
tranquille vers 1h30 cette nuit un
véhicule fou a foncé délibérément sur un
groupe de jeunes qui jouaient à la
console et discutait juste ici derrière
moi blessant trois personnes qui
tentaient de fuir
trois heures plus tard vers 4h30 un
autre véhicule s'arrête le passager
descend et tire au fusil de chasse
blessant sept jeunes
écoutez cet habitant du quartier qui est
venu immédiatement porté secours à ses
voisins je suis descendu et j'ai entendu
pleurer appelé les pompiers appelé les
pompiers
et en effet il y avait des blessés
message je comprends pas c'est la
première fois que ça arrive il ya jamais
de problèmes dans le quartier pour karim
parmi les sept blessés un est dans un
état grave et il a été transféré au chu
de dijon
on ignore les motifs de cette agression
mais dans le quartier on parle de motifs
racistes
écoutez cet ami des victimes qui les a
joints par téléphone
les blessés il parle pas de règlements
de comptes y parle de raciste ils sont
c'est des gens qui sont venus dans le
quartier en insultant de [__] de
raciste et cdd raciste quand il
cherchait la bagarre tout simplement et
sans ils ont dit qu'ils allaient revenir
avec un fusil voilà quoi ils sont venus
puisse en tirer une enquête a été
confiée conjointement au commissariat de
beaune et à la pj de dijon les caméras
de vidéo surveillance présentes dans le
quartier permettront peut-être
d'identifier les auteurs